ah the Oscar goes to I love my life
Denzel Washington this is the fifth
Academy Award nomination for Denzel
Washington into second Oscar he won for
Best Supporting Actor in 1989 of the
Civil War film glory
two birds or one night oh god is good
god is great god is great from the
bottom of my heart I thank you all forty
years I've been chasing Sydney they
finally give it to me what they do they
give it to him the same night I'll
always be chasing you Sydney I'll always
be following in your footsteps there's
nothing I would rather do so nothing
that would better god bless you
oh I want I want to thank the Academy
you know when I was in college first
starting out as an actor they asked each
one of us what we wanted to do I said I
want to be the best actor in the world
all the all the students in the
classroom looked at me like I was a nut
life has taught me to just try and be
the best that I can be and I thank the
Academy for saying to me that on this
given night I was the best that I could
be I want to thank Warner Brothers and
Alan horn and Lorenzo de bottom and Kira
for supporting this film and Antoine
Fuqua a brilliant young filmmaker
african-american filmmaker I don't know
where you are
Antoine loved you ethan hawke my partner
in crime so many people I don't like any
remember everybody lawyers doctors
agents my be a beautiful agent and
LaMotte oh we've been together for so
many years hometown boy from outrunning
my beautiful wife I love him so much you
put up with me in spite of myself and my
beautiful children at home I told you if
I lost tonight I would come home and
we'd celebrate and if I want tonight I
would come home and we'd celebrate well
I'm coming home we're celebrating god
bless you
you